well as ted has been telling us we've
been seeing a lot of rain this past week
and while we have flood control channels
and basins right here in southern nevada
there are some important things to keep
in mind and joining us from the clark
county regional flood control district
the sponsors of today's segment is
michelle french michelle thank you for
being here thanks for having me so this
is a really important thing to talk
about in our community tell me a little
bit about these channels and basins that
are built to help protect us
absolutely we have the regional flood
control district has built 677 miles of
storm facilities that includes storm
channels and storm drains as well as 104
detention basins throughout clark county
wow that sounds like a lot is that a lot
it is a lot and it does a great job to
protect our community from the dangers
of flash flooding but you know we still
see those videos of people taking their
cars out in areas they shouldn't be or
driving when there are those severe
flash flood warnings out there what are
some tips and things that we should keep
in mind before getting in our car and
trying to drive through it all
absolutely there's about
for water
when we have a flash flood if there's
moving water it takes only six inches to
sweep a person off their feet wow 12
inches for a car to be floated and then
18 inches for a large suv
but even going through water even if you
think it's d it's not very deep it could
be deep and you could stall out your
vehicle yeah because sometimes it's hard
to know when you're just looking at the
ground of how high it is what if you
find yourself in a difficult situation
like that do you have any advice for
those drivers
if your vehicle does get stalled in deep
water the best thing for you to do is
get outside of your vehicle and onto the
roof then call 911.
it's a very severe and scary situation
to be in and is there anything else that
you think is important for the public to
know that you guys are doing on your end
to ensure our safety but that we should
be aware of absolutely we we're really
diligent about
reminding our community about the
dangers of flash flooding but most
people maybe those who've lived here for
a while have forgotten about the risk
one and then we have a lot of new
residents who are living here now and
may not understand that we do get flash
flooding and hopefully with these last
few days they're starting to see a
little bit more rain a little bit more
water flowing through the storm channels
and they're becoming aware of it and the
last group of people who are
on our radar as well are new drivers who
may not realize that there is a risk of
driving into flooded waters yeah if
you're not aware of the conditions
especially in our city i think it's a
little unique if people are coming from
elsewhere and just really quickly i want
to talk about every facility is designed
to handle a hundred year storm what does
that mean
so any day we could if it starts raining
we have a risk of having a hundred year
flood
you hear that term thrown around quite a
bit and basically it means that there's
a one percent chance any day of having a
large flood so if we had
two years ago we had a hundred year
flood that doesn't mean we won't have
one for 98 years it could happen today
it could happen tomorrow so we really
want to encourage the community to be
vigilant about flood waters they can go
to our website regionalflood.org to see
rainfall in their community we have
over 222 rain gauges around clark county
so we can really accurately predict how
much rain is happening in the community
itself well michelle thank you so much
for breaking this all down this is
really important information important
to keep in mind especially during
monsoon season so thank you for being
here and all the information is on your
screen thank you to the regional flood
control district for sponsoring this
segment for more information visit
regionalflood.com las vegas now we'll be
right back